X equals 1/3.
We need another step in order
to be able to solve this, and
I'll just added over here.
If necessary, because of parentheses,
distribute anything that's multiplied
to the terms inside the parentheses.
And next you should combine like terms.
So, let's use this complete
process to solve for X here.
There are no fractions to clear, so
we can skip this first step; but
the next step we have to do,
we have to distribute the 3 to
the terms inside the parentheses.
So, 3 needs to be multiplied by X and
by 1.
And when we do that, we got 7 plus
3 times x minus 3 times 1 equals 5.
And we're left with 7 + 3x- 3 = 5.
Let's combine like terms.
7 and 3 are like terms.
7- 3 = 4.
So, 4 + 3x = 5.
Now, we can add or
subtract to get the variable term alone.
We want to subtract 4
from both sides and
we get 0 + 3x = 5- 4.
So, 3x = 1.
Now we multiply or divide, so
the coefficient on the variable is 1.
So, we divide by 3 on both sides.
And x = 1/3.